built in the short economic boom between  two world wars the solver and coal mine  in Germany stands as a reminder of an  industry's past and an architectural  future the sovereign mine was  decommissioned in 1986 after being an  active mine for over 100 years it was  built with conscious thought for the  external appearance and during  redevelopments and expansions in the  1920s adopted a Bauhaus style of  architecture which features a modern  symmetrical and industrial feel and  combines form with function today it  remains open to the public as an  industrial museum and is protected as a  UNESCO World Heritage Site at sovereign  much of the former coal factory has been  left intact allowing visitors to view  the pits railway lines and even the -  housing it is truly a monument of an  industry caught in a moment of history  [Music]  you